in the weeks ahead on AMC's The Walking
Dead we survive we bring civilization
back to this world we are the saviors
they can not be trusted
what exactly are you asking we had today
not only today to find something they
have the numbers there's a price
listen we went farther than we were
supposed to there's nothing left out
here we don't even have enough gas to
keep looking even if we wanted to okay
we said we'd be gone for two weeks it's
been two weeks
as long as hilltop keeps their side of
the bargain we have food at home
we need ammo we need medicine we can't
go back like this there's people
counting on us why are you acting like
you don't know that that's what that
means much to me what we did at the
satellite station why were those people
that we killed you didn't see it okay
you just saw what was left no I had to
do it too yeah we all had to for some
milk and some corn
the only reason and yeah we did you know
we did that's that's the thing you saw
how we were living back home before you
guys got there we don't know we thought
what what it doesn't matter
[Music]
I get it now if it's you or someone else
you choose you you take what you can you
take out who you have to and you get to
keep going nobody's in this together
okay not anymore
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie new Walking
Dead so let's break it down teasing a
new group so I'm gonna explain the
whispers along with this new crew
because I don't think it's the whispers
but I do think that we'll see them
eventually we are the saviors we bring
civilization to the people I love the
negan brainwashing scene here this is
just him holding court with the Savior's
Daryl's standing there in the crowd
we're just gonna get to see a little bit
more of their culture for you also see
Spencer here at the safe zone treating
with them he's still kind of a douche
bag but he had that brief end tag with
Rosita about fighting back so I don't
necessarily think that he's going to
cross the aisle and join the Savior's or
anything like that
that would be a WTF twist so maybe if we
do see something from him like that then
he'll be something of a double agent but
they wouldn't put this scene in the
trailer randomly so this is gonna be
some important moment from next week's
episode we finally catch up with Terra
who runs into another group with Heath
which I'll talk about in just a second I
know it seems like the whispers but even
though we are going to get to them
eventually I don't think that's who that
is there's a bunch of other small groups
that the comic books can introduce when
Morgan and Carole are here at the
kingdom talking about not being able to
trust them I think they want you to
think they're talking about the Savior's
but I think that they've been teasing
another group showing up so they might
be talking about another group but like
the only other group besides the
survivors that we've interacted with at
the kingdom is the Savior's so I just
think they're just like broadening the
dynamic here and it just hammertone the
idea of them fracturing the group the
survivors into a bunch of different
places this season but that gives you
the opportunity like with terrorist
storyline next week to meet another new
group so then you have Rick and Aaron
who also look like they're going to run
into another new group but I wouldn't be
surprised if there's some convergence
here
like you see Tara running into the same
people that Rick and Aaron do but I
think the next new community that we're
going to meet from the comics is going
to be Oceanside which is not the
whispers but they don't debut in the
comics till much later so whoever
they're introducing from the comics they
would still have to move up that reveal
because there are some storylines that
they're speeding through but then
there's the coral stuff that we learned
about this past week so some storylines
are moving slowly like Karl's some are
moving a little
but faster like meeting other new people
so you guys can let me know in the
comments like which new group do you
think it is that they're going to be
running into but the thing about the
whispers is they actually debuted before
Oceanside
but the whispers are like there's such a
big group that I think they're gonna try
and hold off as long as possible but for
all the comic book readers out there who
are trying to plot the season out in
their head just based on how fast
they're moving they did hint to expect
them before most people were expecting
them to show up so the big thing about
the whispers is they are hardcore in the
camo that they wear has like a really
special twist that I'll save for their
actual debut but if you've read the
comics then obviously you know exactly
what's going on it's just the way that
they operate the techniques that they
use that you know just like the
characters themselves are just so much
more hardcore than what we've seen
before not hardcore like negan is a
psychopath hardcore but just the links
that they're willing to go to to survive
so when you hear people talk about alpha
and beta like can't wait for alpha to
show up they're talking about the
whispers she is like the leader of that
group when when they first meet them so
remains to be seen when that's gonna
happen but because we're only in episode
6 I still think it's gonna be a while
before we see them so that would mean
that this new group we meet in Episode
six is somebody else so get hype if you
felt like this past episode was a little
slow I feel like this is the answer to
that they've kind of been doing that
this season where they have like a
really big sprawling episode with a
bunch of crazy action then they have an
episode that's just relatively
self-contained with fewer characters
it's a little bit quieter then they go
back to super crazy so if you guys want
I'll still do that Carl Grimes rumor
video but it is a rumor and it could be
potentially spoilery depending on
whether or not it's true so I am
hesitant to do it but if you guys want
me to just let me know in the comments
and I'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Elliot McDonald
you want a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details the next round of the giveaway
will start when I post my next Walking
Dead video so there is some cool comic
book cyborg Superman stuff happening
later tonight so there might be a third
video for cyborg superman or you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for this week's Walking Dead episode
and you can click here for this week's
Westworld thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight